alors donc c'est encore PAF avec Babin
et nous sommes avec toute l'équipe avec
Pascal la tour duupin qui nous a fait un
résumé de ce qui s'est passé un samedi
matin vers 5h30 en Israël alors ça a été
dans l'actualité tout le weekend bien
entendu les chaînes info nont parlait
que de ça les chaînes normales aussi et
c'est vrai que il y a plein de questions
qu'on se pose on va se les poser avec Al
ber dans un instant mais juste vous quel
est votre sentiment ici parce que
j'aimerais qu'on parle aussi de ce qui
s'est passé aussi et de ce qui se passe
actuellement sur les réseaux sociaux et
cetera on voit beaucoup beaucoup de
choses circuler Gill quel a été ton
sentiment toi ce weekend l'ffroid euh
leseffroid de voir comme ça une
organisation terroriste attaquer des des
des gens massacrer des gens lesffroid
terribles et très vite tout de suite
cyril a la peur de la propagation de
cette haine au niveau mondial peur d'un
embrasement régional et et et peur que
les patients s'exacerbent et que ça
rejaillisse aussi en France bien sûr
solidarité totale avec les victimes
absolu mais tout de suite je me suis dit
que ça pouvait aussi fracturer notre
société qui est si fragile en ce moment
donc voilà lese frroid par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé et une certaine peur que
cela arrive en France d'une manière ou
d'une autre avec une exacerbation des
sentiments
et j'espère j'espère que ça ne
débouchera pas sur une fracturation de
notre société voilà géraline je t'
vouloir intervenir tout à l'heure oui
quand alors effectivement oui l'roid
choqué par cette attaque massive bar bar
est absolument immonde mais en fait tout
à l'heure vous montriez les images de la
rive avec ces jeunes et vous avez dit
que ces jeunes ils étaient là pour la
paix pour voilà ils étaient pas là pour
faire de la politique ils avaient pas de
positionnement mais en fait c'est pas le
problème du Hamas en fait le Hamas il
est pas là pour savoir ce qu'il pense il
est là pour les anéantir parce qu'ils
sont juifs il est là pour raser un pays
c'est le projet c'est le sur le c'est le
djihad du Hamas c'est leur projet
politique ils sont pas là pour leur
peuple non plus ils sont pas là pour les
Palestiniens ils sont juste là pour
faire disparaître un pays et faire
disparaître un peuple voilà et donc je
pense qu'effectivement Gil a raison je
pense que les prochaines peut-être même
années vont être très turbulentes très
agitées ce sera aussi compliqué de en
France parce qu'on on est un pays où t
tous ces thèmes là sont très exacerbés
en prenant parole ce soir la parole ce
soir on peut être soit courageux soit
lâche alors on peut être factuel mais en
prenant position ce soir en disant
certains mots ben je pense que on risque
on risque pour nous aussi je pense c'est
des des thématiques justement on va en
parler dans un instant on va parler dans
un instant tout ça tout ce voilà les
menaces le plateau ici les on a on a pas
le droit d'ouvrir les les fenêtres par
exemple du studio parce qu'aujourd'hui
on a peur pour notre sécurité donc ça ça
devient carrément fou donc évidemment
voilà donc évidemment très choqué et
surtout très très angoissé Yann mon cher
Cyril ce soir vous avez instauré une
belle solinité sur le plateau il y a pas
eu de musique il y a pas eu
d'applaudissement et ce que vous avez
fait est très important c'est d'habitude
on fait ça quand quand il y a un
attentat sur le sol français donc là on
a tous pris la mesure que il y avait
quelque chose qui se passait entre
guillemets loin mais qui était
infiniment proche de nous et un jour
j'ai eu une conversation avec vous dans
votre loge et vous m'aviez dit que une
des raisons pour laquelle vous faisiez
cette émission c'est que vous vouliez
éviter Coutte que cûe l'importation de
ce genre de conflit sur le territoire
français que vous aviez une mission vous
qui êtes tellement écouté par tous les
milieux toutes les castes de la société
et toutes les religions possibles que
vouliez vraiment incarner celui qui
voulait éviter l'importation de ce genre
d'événement sur le territoire français
et c'est aussi pour ça que cette
émission d'une certaine manière est
importante il y a quelque chose de très
important que les jeunes téléspectateurs
doivent savoir il y a deux institutions
palestiniennes il y a une institution
palestinienne officielle qui est en fait
les autorités palestiniennes
sjordaniennes qui reconnaissent comme
voisin et souvent comme ennemis les
Israéliens et il y a une autre
institution qui est terroristique et les
institutions terroristiques c'est une
sorte de de difficulté de joindre ces
deux mots mais c'est la vérité aussi au
Liban avec le hzbollah qui est une
institution mais qui va armer au
Parlement là il y a une entité qui est à
la fois institutionnelle et terroriste
c'est dans la bande de Gaza lorsque vous
AZ mis musulmans cher Cyril vous ont dit
vous ont dit ça parce que moi moi mes
amis musulmans de quoi ils ont peur ils
ont peur que il y a un amalgame entre
ils en peuvent plus ça ça ils en peuvent
plus en France que quand voilà et ça ils
veulent plus de d'AMG et ça leur fait
beaucoup de mal ce genre de chos mais si
je peux me permettre vous savez que la
plupart des Gazaouis c'est-à-dire des
Palestiniens qui sont dans la bande de
Gaza pensent comme vos amis musulmans
simplement ils vivent dans une dictature
ils sont plus proches la plupart des
Gazaoui du gouvernement israélien qu'ils
ne le sont des terroristes qui les
humili et qui les bride sur la bande de
Gaza toute la journée et qui sont les
gens du Hamas il faut savoir ils ne
vivent pas dans une dictature et vous
savez dans toutes les dictatures euh ils
vivent dans une dicture dans toutes les
dictatures vous savez comment on existe
d'une seule façon c'était vrai pendant
la France en 1793 c'est vrai en Corée du
Nord et dans toutes les dictatures et en
dans l'Allemagne Nazi faire la guerre si
vous ne faites pas la guerre vous ne
pouvez pas obtenir de mandat officiel de
votre peuple et vous ne pouvez pas
donner à votre peuple ou soi-disant
peuple la moindre euh le moindre ordre
si vous voulez ils sont pris dans une
sorte d'étau les Palestiniens entre deux
mots il faut choisir le moindre mais je
vous assure qu'ils sont les Gazaouis
dans le même lot que vos amis musulmans
ils aimeraient bien ne pas avoir à
choisir entre Israël et le Hamas bien
sûr on pense et on a une grosse pensée
bien sûr pour toutes les familles hein
des victimes et il y a énormément aussi
de de de personnes en France qui ont de
la famille là-bas et qui sont très très
inquiets de ce qui se passe à tout
moment c j'ai oublé parce que c'est pour
finir mon
raisonnement la haine du Hamas ne se
dresse pas contre les Israéliens mais
pas du tout elle se dresse contre les
Juifs pourquoi quand vous humiliez des
gens quand vous fr quand vous crachez
sur des cadavre vous ne crachez pas
contre des Israéliens vous ne faites pas
de politique vous avez bien vu que ce
n'est pas une attaque militaire ce n'est
pas une guerre de militaire envers
militaire dès lors qu'on s'en prend à
des civils on est dans la barbarie et
donc on ne s'en prend pas à des soldats
on s'en prend à des gens parce qu'ils
sont juifs ça veut bien dire que le
Hamas se moque complètement des
Israéliens et vous savez comment la vous
savez comment le Hamas oblige les
Palestiniens dire le mot israélien ben
ce mot n'existe pas on dit juif en
général salale juif donc le mot
d'Israélien n'existe même pas dans la
langue du Palestiniens de Gaza Valérie
MIM oui je je souscris à tout ce que
vient de dire Yann ce sont des
terroristes armés par des pays
totalitaires étrangers ils ne veulent
absolument pas soutenir la cause
palestinienne ce qui les intéresse c'est
pas deux états parce qu'on parle de
processus de paix ils ne veulent pas
deux états ils veulent éradiquer l'État
d'Israël et par là même l'existence même
du peuple juif ça c'est le premier prier
point donc effectivement le Hamas
confisque confisque la cause
palestinienne et les Palestiniens sont
les otages du Hamas et lorsque les le
les les terroristes sont arrivés sur le
sol israélien ils ont voulu tuer des
juifs ils ont voulu tuer le processus de
paix parce que en ce moment il y avait
également un processus de de
normalisation avec le Qatar avec
l'Arabie Saoudite pardonz-moi et donc
évidemment ça ne les arrange pas et moi
à quel moment à quel moment ces images
ont ont confisqué l'humanité des uns et
des autres à quel moment les gens
certains n'ont vu que des juifs tués et
pas des êtres humains des enfants des
grand-mères des mamans et cetera parce
que quand je vois certains tweet oui
mais
8 mai 8 mai à quel moment il y a un 8
mai il y a une condamation c'est pas
c'est pas le moment pour le 8 mai
exactement ce ser jamais ban il a sepre
pas pardonnez-moi juste vrais terminer
juste moi je pense que cette histoire
j'ai entendu c'est l'affaire des Juifs
et c'est l'affaire des juifs et des
Arabes c'est ni l'affaire des Juifs ni
l'affaire des juifs et des Arabes c'est
l'affaire de l'humanité en ce moment par
exemple à Paris il y a une manifestation
c'est pas une manifestation qui est
l'affaire des Juifs c'est une
manifestation qui est l'affaire de tous
tout le monde devrait y être parce que à
partir du moment on vous demande pas
d'être ami avec Israël ou amis avec le
gouvernement de netaniaou on vous
demande d'être ennemi du du terrorisme
donc si vous êtes ennemi du terrorisme B
vous pouvez participer par exemple
manifestation posera les les CIN
questions dans un instant et d'ailleurs
on parlera de ce qui peut se passer en
France bien entendu avec tout ce qui se
passe là-bas aujourd'hui bien entendu
l'important c'est aussi d'avoir une
énorme pensée pour les victimes pour les
familles des victimes et pour ce drame
inommable qu'il y a eu samedi
et de balier tous les sujets et
notamment le sujet de la prise de parole
sur les réseaux
sociaux j'ai vu je vous le dis moi je
trouve ça inadmissible voilà de voir des
gens qui mettent le drapeau d'Israël se
faire insulter se faire menacer de mort
actuellement il y a aussi des gens qui
ont mis le drapeau
palestinien euh hier avanttiè et ça a
été sur les réseaux sociaux une guerre
des réseaux sociaux entre ceux qui
mettaient le drapeau d'Israël ceux qui
mettaient le drapeau Palestine cette
guerre des réseaux sociaux c'est un fléo
euh sachez-le et moi j'ai eu je vous dis
des des centaines de sms vous le savez
j'ai j'ai voilà vous savez je je voilà
je je plein d'amis musulmans qui m'ont
envoyé plein de messages Cyril on est
avec toi Cyril c'est un
drame quand on voit ces guerres sur les
réseaux sociaux qui vont déboucher par
des guerres dans la rue par des des des
des actes barbarie dans la rue des actes
antisémites des actes racistes c'est
inadmissible je vous dis même dans les
écoles je vois il y a des positions moi
mon fils j'ai toujours envie que son
meilleur ami ce soit Edie qui est
confession musulmane j'ai pas envie que
demain ce soit plus son meilleur ami
parce que c'est un garçon que j'adore
qui est formidable et on lui demande pas
mon fils lui demande pas quelle est ta
religion s'amuse avec lui c'est un
garçon qui qui a toujours été là ses
parents sont formidables ses parents
sont musulmans ils sont très en plus ils
sont très religieux voilà il pratiquent
beaucoup et il est bien avec eux il fait
des fêtes musulmanes avec eux il est
content il fait les fêtes juiv avec nous
il est content on fait les fêtes voilà
j'ai pas envie de ça j'ai pas envie
qu'il y ait aujourd'hui en France quand
je suis avec mes potes tar ou qui est là
qui vient de m'envoyer un mot d'ailleurs
j'ai pas envie qu'il y a de la défiance
on dis qu'est-ce qui se passe on n'est
pas là-dedans on connaît pas on peut pas
transporter ici un problème qu'on
connaît tous pas sur le bout des doigts
je vous le dis ah il y a pas une
personne ici ce soit dans le public
autour du plateau qui peut vous
donner vraiment tous les tenants et les
aboutissants de l'affaire trop complexe
c'est extrêmement complexe et on n pas
sur le terrain on sait pas donc on voit
quoi on voit ce que nous monre les
médias on voit ce que ce qu'on voit sur
les réseaux on peut pas on peut on ne
peut pas c'est comme je pense quand tu
es t quand tu es allé quand tu es
allé y tu allé en Corée Coré du Nord
exactement on tu avais vu plein de
choses d'ici quand tu es allé là-bas on
peut faire un parallèle c'est de voir
quand quand un peuple n'a pas voix au
chapitre ouais quand un peuple est
enfermé sous cloches non mais le truc
c'est je fais pas je fais pas un
parallèle entre les deux mais je te dis
que on on on nous dit plein de choses
aussi mais quand tu es sur le terrain
c'est pas la même chose là on ne peut
pas euh personne ne connaît le sujet sur
le bout des doigts il y a a on dit des
spécialistes en France on a r depuis de
jours on voit que des spécialistes la PL
la plupart des gens qui se qui se
déchirent sur réseaux sociaux sont
incapables de mettre la carte sur la
carte du monde l'endroit où se trouve
précisément Israël exctement aujourd'hui
on veut pas de guerre
euh en France entre les Juifs et les
musulmans moi j'ai pas envie voilà que
qu'il ait des tensions ça ça serait la
pire des choses vous remarquerez quand
même Cyril que ceux qui sont le plus
menacés en France aujourd'hui ne sont
pas les musulmans mais ce sont les
Israéliens ou les Juifs et pourquoi ils
sont menacer parce que ils ont été
victimes de cet horrible attentat samedi
dernier donc cela va
menace et tout est dit